hey if you want to get some epic anime
merch that you're not gonna find
anywhere else check out our online store
anime out Broadcom we have Eskin or
praise the Sun Mele Otis feel the wrath
bond love the pain more esken or more
Mele Otis and other things too so check
us out link in the description what is
up everybody its Anna Mac here for anime
uproar and today there will be no video
it will just be me sobbing hysterically
for like 15 minutes while drinking hot
cocoa okay guys
cool or alright fine I will man up and
actually try to tackle what just
happened into seven deadly sins we just
witnessed perhaps the single most
beautiful and tragic moment in the
entire series and I am so conflicted
because from a storytelling perspective
this was amazing but from an emotional
perspective this was devastating
and I will be telling you all about it
right here in this video if you enjoyed
the seven deadly sins content right here
on the channel and you'd like to see
more please leave a like to let me know
it really helps and if you happen to be
new to anime or don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications finally
this video will contain major seven
deadly sins manga spoilers so if you're
not caught up to the manga I advise you
strongly to leave right now proceed with
extreme caution
chapter 333 starts off with gelda and
zelgius departing presumably for the
demon realm also known as the underworld
as the sands mile and Elizabeth waved to
them the sins are overjoyed because of
the fact that the demon king is finally
gone after all this time but then our
focus shifts to something else everyone
turns to
esken or who as we know pushed himself
way beyond his limits in this battle you
will recall that mile warned us Kannur
even before the battle that his body was
reaching its limits and that he would
die if he overexerted himself but
instead of heeding miles advice esken or
pushed himself further than ever before
in fact he somehow moved beyond the one
in order to attain a new even more
powerful ultimate Eskin or for
or the other sins look to s Canora and
they are hopeful that after this battle
they can all go home together
but s Kannur tells them that
unfortunately he cannot even move his
body anymore and he says that this is
the end for him nevertheless s Kannur
makes it clear that he has no regrets
and that he is glad that he got to meet
and got to know all of the sins he
speaks directly to the sins Elizabeth
and my L and thanks them for everything
they've done for him or gives them some
parting advice he even thanked smile but
I'm not even going to get into it about
miles since I ranted in my previous
video about how he just bitched out on
the whole battle against the demon king
s kannur then tells meliodas that he
owes his life to him and he calls
meliodas a true friend to whom there
could never be an equal finally s kannur
tells Merlin the truth he tells her what
we've all been hoping to hear come out
of his mouth for so long s Kannur says
that he's always loved Merlin not just
because she reminded him of Rosa but
because she saw him as more than just a
freak or a monster she treated him as a
person without prejudice despite his
strange and terrifying power and this is
what made s Kannur fall in love with
Merlin Merlin jokes that s Kannur may be
giving her too much credit since she
loves research and experimentation so
maybe she was just fascinated by asking
horse power and she was studying him as
a subject in order to further her
knowledge of magic but s Kannur says
that even that would be enough for him
to be happy as long as he was able to
exist in some corner of her heart
somewhere this moment was so
heartwarming and heartbreaking I'm not
saying I cried but I'm not saying I
didn't cry either so make of that what
you will
then Merlin says something really
interesting she says to s Kannur you're
too late too late for anything for
everything some things just can't be
taken back s Kannur I wish you could
have found me sooner if possible three
thousand years sooner both Elizabeth
that meliodas seemed confused by what
Merlin is saying here which is
fascinating because we know that
Elizabeth and when the oldest did know
Merlin even three thousand years ago in
fact Elizabeth and Merlin were really
close in
and cold Elizabeth her big sis sis but
they don't seem to know exactly what
Merlyn is talking about here s kadar
says to Merlin no matter what happens
I'm always on your side no matter what
decisions you've made what crimes or
sins you bear
Merlin looks up in surprise and says you
knew but s kadar says that no he just
had a gut feeling that Merlin was hiding
some deep regret since from the very
moment he saw her she always had such
sadness in her eyes I'm really not sure
what exactly Merlin is referring to here
what sin or crimes she committed askin
or doesn't know and seemingly neither do
Elizabeth and meliodas perhaps they're
just referring to the fact that 3,000
years ago
Merlin tricked the demon king and the
supreme deity and as a result of her
trickery the two divine beings decided
to punish her by destroying her hometown
belly allowin the capital of the Wizards
we've always assumed that this was
Merlin's sin she was a glutton for
knowledge and because of her gluttony an
entire city was destroyed so maybe this
is what Merlin is referring to the fact
that so many people in her hometown died
because of her perhaps this is why her
eyes are always sad and why her heart
could not love anyone for these past
3,000 years but I kind of assumed that
the fate of Billy Alwyn wasn't a secret
and I never got the sense from Merlin
that she had great regrets about this
event in particular however it could be
that Merlin just kept her feelings
bottled up inside so that is why we
never realized how she truly felt and
all the regrets she had this is
definitely a possibility but perhaps
there is some other regret that Merlin
has something that has not yet been
revealed at this current point in the
story Merlin is the only sin whose
backstory has not been explored beyond a
few brief panels there has been no focus
in the main story on Merlin's origins
and we haven't had any side stories
focusing on Merlin's background either
we know a lot more about the back
stories of all the other main characters
than we do about Merlin's backstory
during that my Alistair Ossa arc I made
videos in which I speculated that Merlin
had something to do with ending the
previous holy war and that she had
something to do with the divine grace
sunshine leaving Myles body and
eventually choosing esque
nor as a vessel I had this idea because
Merlin is said to have studied magic
under the original Golder the same
person who was responsible for ending
the holy war by making everyone think
that my L was a demon called esta rosa i
wonder whether Merlin's regret from
3,000 years ago could have something to
do with the original goal thir and how
the previous holy war ended
perhaps Merlin was somehow responsible
for Eskin or inheriting sunshine which
ultimately led to all of his hardships
I'm just speculating at this point but
we definitely need a chapter or two
about Merlin's backstory we've had a
much more detailed backstory for
everyone else so I hope that in the
coming chapters we will finally learn
more about Merlin at this point s
Connors body begins to evaporate as if
sunshine is burning through it and using
it up s kannur says that it looks like
he is just about out of time and he
warns everyone to step back just in case
his body becomes so unstable that it
explodes and causes damage to the
surrounding area the sins are all
devastated by what is happening as s
Kannur says one last farewell to Merlin
but Merlin has had enough she straight
up does the deal walk towards Eskin or
as he warns her to stay back because
it's dangerous as everyone looks on in
surprise Merlin kisses s Kannur right on
the lips roll do you know how long I've
been waiting for this moment for Merlin
to finally kiss s Kannur and now that it
finally happened it happens in this
freakin moment ah
Merlin says that she was never able to
reciprocate her feelings for esken or
presumably due to the sadness that she
carried in her heart for over 3,000
years
but she says that as proof that s Canora
existed she has taken these burns on her
body as a symbol of the one man who ever
loved her and we can see that the lower
side of Merlin's face is now scarred
around the mouth because she kissed s
Canora as he was burning up s Kannur
looks upon her with tears in his eyes
and he recites one final poem the finest
of wines able to love the heart into the
sweetest intoxication that is your
only love regrettably I wasn't able to
become the glass that could hold it but
if you could grant me one wish God it
would be for a glass able to hold that
love to one day appear then as Merlin
and everyone else looks on with profound
sadness in their eyes s Connors body
evaporates and the master of the Sun Big
Daddy sunshine is no more on the final
page the words sleep well as kannur
appear along with the text that reads
even the mightiest has fallen and gone
with the wind dude what did this really
just happen I waited so long for that
kiss and this is what happens right
after I made a whole video in
collaboration with Cuusoo mati about
what s Kannur and Merlin's daughter
might look like and now this happens
I can't even honestly I am almost
speechless here and I talk a lot I talk
for a living so being speechless is not
a familiar feeling to me realistically
this major and heartbreaking death has
been foreshadowed heavily in the
previous chapters we saw that s Kunal
was committed to saving his friends at
all costs we saw that he was willing to
sacrifice his own life to help them and
we saw that he was perhaps too willing
to put his own life on the line because
of how difficult his life has been and
because of how much he feels he owes to
his friends the sins but even knowing
all of that and knowing that something
like this could happen I didn't want to
believe and I truly wanted to believe
that naka bouzouki was just trolling us
again with all of this foreshadowing he
has definitely done it many times before
and I so badly wanted s Connor and
Merlin to get together and just live
happily ever after I am honestly
heartbroken don't get me wrong this was
an amazing chapter one of the best
chapters in the history of the seven
deadly sins it was so moving it was so
deep it was such an emotional roller
coaster I love this chapter it is
beautiful but it is also so damn tragic
I'm trying to think back now and I know
that in the seven deadly sins we have
definitely seen characters straight up
coming back to life from the dead
or reincarnating in the case of
Elizabeth we've seen it with Mellie Otis
we've seen it with the people Elizabeth
was able to save from the brink of death
with her goddess powers we've seen it
with Elaine but every time something
like that happened the body of the
character had still been intact with the
exception of Elizabeth and reincarnation
of course as much as I hate to admit it
this could be one of the few deaths in
the seven deadly sins that actually
sticks and that sucks so much because
it's Big Daddy sunshine that we're
talking about here the tragic poet the
heroic human the man of culture who had
the privilege of rubbing down Merlin
while she was taking a bath I really
don't know what to say right now man I
am left wondering what is going to
happen to sunshine now is it going to
return to my L or go somewhere else also
where exactly does Merlin's sadness come
from what secrets is her backstory
hiding and are we ever going to find out
more about her finally what about King
Arthur whose potential return was
foreshadowed in the past and what about
the supreme deity who created sunshine
in the first place and who is still
apparently just chilling out somewhere
in the celestial realm there are so many
questions and so much heartbreak in this
freaking chapter chapter 333 is one that
I will never forget okay now seriously
guys please let me know what you thought
of this chapter and about what just
happened are you as devastated as I am
do you really think that this is the end
of Eskin or no magical revivals nor
reincarnations also what is going to
happen next in the story
what could possibly follow this
incredible and devastating chapter
please share your thoughts with me down
in the comments below if you want to see
more seven deadly sins content right
here on the channel don't forget to
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed yet please do me
a favor and subscribe and hit that
notification bell also feel free to hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime upper patrons for
supporting our work and making videos
like this one possible special thank you
to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh be
beerain nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress $30 beat accordion Anatoly
Cassatt's key DJ Nathaniel alpha do and
on he'll cool
I can't forget our the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all other clans
including Ingrid ah a lowland out of
Maddie Mac makoto-kun Seth Cooper and
the world and you know he's serious
because he didn't say it's a wild doll
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you please
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]